[Music]
but Nally night is here tell me about
this look I'm giving you the old hello
I'm giving you the brightest pungent
star girl whoa obviously the splendors
has been one of the most iconic moments
of season ten so I wanted to do a very
elevated glam and high customer moment
of a sponge dress this is like my floral
elven queen if you've ever seen Fern
Gully
the the mother fairy I think this kind
of resembles her a little bit my look
tonight is actually inspired by gone
with the wind
it's the Scarlett O'Hara opening dress
because my last name actually came from
the movie Gone with with because I'm
what Gone with the Wind fabulous John
fabulous Gone with the Wind fabulous
okay
thank you I wanted something very
ceremonial for this moment because it's
so important it's a milestone in my
career and rate is such a powerful color
and a color that I've reserved for
moments like this I just wanted to be
very simple I think I do simple well so
I just wanted to be chic black very
Madonna erotica meets you know Dior and
trash bags like America I'm gonna give
y'all some Browns the legendary
something iconic it's a very very bad
there everything in BAP meets to Wong
food this is I'm you know black girl
magic is my life and I just wanted to
come out and show some royalty and some
magic oh honey I don't give you a little
lever moment I knew the girls were going
to be all sparkly and bedazzled I was
like let's go with a little glamour with
a little flare of edge all black today
are we in morning what was the
inspiration for this yes it's late
afternoon but I am in early morning
everybody it has been such a difficult
years
I'm a rocker I'm a punk rock [ __ ] so
like you know what I'm gonna take that
I'm gonna turn it into something that's
right up my style and this is what we
did tonight I think you can tell it's
very Asian inspired because I'm so proud
of my heritage and culture that I'm
gonna embrace it and also glorify and
show people that I'm very proud of it in
my home state we have my home state in
New Mexico we have the most amazing
sunsets so I really wanted to go with
like all the colors of the sunset that
you know that we get to enjoy back home
and I wanted to create this beautiful
ensemble just to make a lasting ever
pressure on the rest of the world
[Music]
[Applause]